شكرا فاطمه مشاهدينا نرحب بكم في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه الجديده من تغطيتنا
المتواصله لتطورات الاوضاع في السودان
لليوم الثالث على التوالي بينما تستمر
الاشتباكات اقر الجيش بدخول قوات الدعم
السريع الى مطار مروي العسكري متعهدا
باستعادته في اقرب وقت بينما اكد الجيش ان
جميع مقرات القياده العامه تحت السيطره
رغما الاشتباكات الضاريه التي تدور منذ
ساعه الصباح لكن في المقابله لا تزال قوات
الدعم السريع تؤكد سيطرتها على مقرات
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
طبيعه الاحداث التي تحدث منذ الاول من امس
هي محلات اشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحامات بعدد
من المقرات العسكريه نحن نتصدى لهذه
المحاولات
واضافه الى ان هنالك عمليات قنص واستهداف
لطباطنا وجنودنا تم جرس محاولات
لاعتقال القبض على
افرادنا ضباطنا وجنودنا
الى مواقعهم مواقع عملهم الرسميه تم
القبض على واقول اما القبض على العديد من
الضباط الذين هم دارسون في دورات
الاستخبارات او ضباط توجهوا الى الى مواقع
عملهم في الصباح تم اعتقالهم واعتبارهم
جذوع بشريه في مقرات مليشياء الدعم السريع
سباكات اليوم محدوده جدا اقل عده بكثير من
اليوم الاول من الامس نحن نعصر عملياتنا
في هذه المرحله في التصدي لمحاولاتهم
اقتحام بعض المواقع مقرات القوات المسلحه
في محيط القياده العامه جميع مقرات
القياده العامه هي الان تحت يد مسيطره
القياده العامه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو طلب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات نقلتها
وكاله روترز من حسابه على تويتر طالب
المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد
ما اسماه جرائم رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
هذا ونشر الجيش السوداني بين انتهى من
خلاله قوات الدعم السريع بممارسه اعمال
سلب ونهب لممتلكات المواطنين بيان الجيش
اكد سيطرته على جميع مقرات القياده العامه
مشيرا الى عدم صحه سيطره الدعم السريع على
بيت الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه وقال البيان ان القوات الجويه
للجيش تنفذ ضربات ضد عناصر الدعم السريع
في الخرطوم
تؤكد انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميديشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مخرطه في هذا العامة
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه التعذيب مضلله الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا في القوات المسلحه لاننا
قوات محترفه وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم
تماما بجميع قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه
الحالات نحن نتقيد تماما
بمقررات القانون الدولي الانساني قانون
المسلحه في هذا النزاع المسلح
قبل ذلك نفى مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للعربيه ما تم نشره من قبل قوه الدعم
السريع حول اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد
المصدر للعربيه ان الاشتباكات جرت حول
مقري البرهان واحميتي وتم ابعادها وان
فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر البرهان
مضلل وغير حقيقي
[تصفيق]
والمزيد من متابعه انضم الينا من مروي
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك الان
المعلومات هي اجواء الحذر التي تحيط الان
بقاعده مروي العسكريه وتحيط بمطار مروي
بعد نقر الجيش السوداني بدخول قوات الدعم
السريع حسب بيان الجيش او تصريحاته لقناه
العربيه قبل قليل
الاوضاع الان هادئه في محيط الخيره ومحيط
المطار لا سماع لاصوات رصاص لا سماع الان
لمدفعيه ثقيله لا سماع لما يمكن ان ينبع
عن اشتباكات بين قوات المسلحه السودانيه
وبين قوات الدعم السريع
مواطنون ايضا في مدينه مروي المطله مباشره
على القاعده وعلى المطار
ترقب وفي حاله توتر خاصه بعد ان اشار
الجيش السوداني بانه قد تعهد باستعاده هذه
القاعده هو المطار خلال هذا اليوم
وهذا يشير ايضا حسب المعلومات يمكن ان
تحدث الاشتباكات وعمليه عسكريه مجددا لذلك
الحذر هو التوتر هو ما يسيطر الان على
الموقف
مروي وفي القاعده وفي المطار يعني نفهم من
ذلك بانه لا يوجد ما ينبئ بمحاوله الجيش
السوداني اقتحام
القاعده من جديد
واستعادتها من قوات الدعم السريع التي اقر
المتحدث باسم الجيش بانها دخلت اليها
اليوم هذا ما افهمه من كلامك
نعم حتى الان لم تقدم وحدات الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه بوحداتها
المختلفه سواء كان عبر المدفعيه او عبر
القوات البريه او عبر القوات الجويه لم
يقدم بهذه التشكيلات على اقتحام او الدخول
الى القاعده الوضع كما هو عليه ليس هنالك
من جديد
نراقب ونتابع ونعطي جديد الاخبار
والتحديثات طيب ماذا عن الاوضاع الانسانيه
داخل مدينه مروي خصوصا قبل ايام من عيد
الفطر كيف
يتعامل السودانيون مع هذه الظروف
السوق الرئيسي في هذه المدينه الذي يقدم
الخدمات الاساسيه المواد الغذائيه الشرب
المياه القمح كل المعينات والمعينات
الغذائيه في هذا السوق الرئيس الذي يضم
اكبر نسبه من المرحله التجاريه هذا السوق
الان مغلق
ليس بحذر التجوال رسمي مفروض من قبل
السلطات الامنيه او لجنه امن الولايه
الشماليه ولكن نتيجه لتخوف المواطنين
والتخوف التجار عليه توقفت الحركه
التجاريه حتى حركه المواصلات الداخليه
متوقفه حركه المواصلات التي تنقل
المواطنين عبر الباصات السفريه من مروي
الى العاصمه الخرطوم عبر مدينه ام درمان
وعبر مدينه عبره متوقفه بالنسبه للتخوف
المواطنين ومن اصحاب السفريه من الاقدام
على سلوك الطريق البري القومي وتعرضهم لاي
اشتباكات او يكون جزء من عمليه عمليه
عسكريه
المواطنون الان فيما يلي الوضع الغذائي
والوضع الامني الامور مستقره في مدينه
مروي هنالك انقطاع للكهرباء بعض الاحياء
انقطعت فيها خدمه المياه
الاتصالات احدى شركات الاتصالات المتوقفه
لكن هنالك شركات تعمل خدمه الانترنت
متوقفه ايضا في احدى الشركات لكنها متوفره
في شركات اخرى الطرق داخل المدينه سالكه
الجسر الذي يربط بين مدينه مروي وبين
مدينه كريمه سالك الحركه فيه تنظيفها هي
عليه الجيش ايضا يتركز في مدينه مروي في
بعض
هل ذهب الناس الى اعمالهم هذا يوم عمل
رسمي تم الاعلان عن عطله في ثاني يوم ايام
الاشتباكات لكن الان كيف يتعامل الناس مع
الاعمال خصوصا موظفوا الحكومه طلاب
المدارس
كل المؤسسات الرسميه الحكوميه مغلقه مغلقه
بالكامل ليس هنالك من دوام رسمي للموظفين
وللعاملين في سلك الحكومي حتى الاعمال
التجاريه الخاصه متوقفه المحاله التجاريه
الصغيره
المحل التي تقدم خدمات السيارات متوقفه
كل هذه العناصر التي
تقدم اشاره على ان الحياه المدنيه تمضي
على وثيرتها المعتاده متوقفه بحكم التخوف
وبحكم الترقب لمالات الساعات اي حركه او
اي نشاط اعتيادي مدني سيتاثر بفعل اطلاق
رصاصه واحده وهو ما حدث خلال اليومين
الماضيين عندما اندلعت الاشتباكات صباحا
مباشره فر المواطنون خاصه الذين يقطنون
بالقرب من المطار والقاعده الى داخل
المدينه والى الاحياء الامنه المواطنون
يتخوفون من ان تندلع الاشتباكات يتخوفون
من ان تمتد الاعين
واصوات الغذائف
واصوات الاليات الثقيله والشظايا الى داخل
المدينه لذلك هم داخل المنازل
يغلقون ابواب المنازل
المدينه في حاله الصمت تام الحركه ضئيله
وبسيطه للغايه عاد الذين يضطرون الى
الخروج لشراء بعض المستلزمات الرئيسي
على موضوع
الوضع الصحي في مره ولكن قبل ذلك ماذا عن
الامن والامان يعني هل تتولى قوات الشرطه
استثباب الامن في المدينه هل تم تسجيل اي
عمليات سلب ونهب او تهديد لحياه المواطنين
خلال فتره الاضطراب التي سادت منذ ثلاثه
ايام بعدين اندلاع هذه الاشتباكات
الشيء الذي يجب ان يوضح فيه في هذه
المساله مساله الاشتباكات ومساله تاثيرات
هذه العمليات العسكريه على واقع المدنيين
وعلى امن وعلى سم المدنيين مسرح العمليه
يختلف عن العاصمه الخرطوم العاصمه الخرطوم
استشهد فيها الاحياء عمليات عسكريه تشهد
فيها مناطق ومحيط القياده عمليات مناطق
متفرقه اما هنا في مروي فمسرح العمليه
العسكريه هو فقط داخل حدود مطار مروي
وداخل القاعده اما هنا في داخل مدينه مروي
لم
لم تسجل مضا الشرطه حتى الان او لم يتنام
الى علمنا او لم تاتينا مصادر بشكل طبيعي
شكرا على التوضيح في هذه النقطه تحديدا
نعود الى الوضع الصحي والمستشفيات وكيف
تسير هذه العمليه بشكل عام
داخل مدينه كريمه هنالك ثلاثه مستشفيات
رئيسه مستشفى قومي عسكري يقدم خدمته
للقوات النظاميه ويقدم خدماته للمدنيين
هنالك ايضا مستشفى حكومي ومستشفى خاص هذه
المستشفيات حسب المعطيات التي نشاهدها
الان قوم بواجباتها تقدم الخدمات الصحيه
خاصه لجرحى ومصابي القوات النظاميه
القوانين المسلحه الذين اصيبوا امس وامس
الاول خلال العمليه العسكريه داخل مطار
لكن لا توجد تقديرات لاعداد المصابين
الذين وصلوا الى هذه المستشفيات
الذين تم حصرهم خلال الساعات الماضيه نحو
خمسين من القوات المسلحه السودانيه ربما
تزيد هذه النسبه لكن لم تصدر بعض بيانات
رسميه توضح النسبه التي ازدادت بها اعداد
المصابين والجرحى توزعوا في مدينه مروي
التي دارت فيها الاشتباكات وتوزعوا ايضا
في مدينه كريمه في الجانب الغربي او
الشرقي من نهر النيل وايضا تم ضعف او تم
ارسال بعض المصابين الى مدينه بنغلا
لتلقوا العلاج اللازم والازعافات الاوليه
في تقديرات او روايات من المستشفيات حسب
شهود عيان عن وصول جثث او ان فقط من يتم
ارسالهم هم المصابين
من يصل الى المستشفيات هما المصابون
تحدثنا الى بعض القاده العسكريين عن
الضحايا هذه العمليات العسكريه في مطار
مروي اشاروا
بانه سيصدر بيان ليس الان تحديدا لكن
سيصدر بيان توضيحي
للراي العام يوضح كل التفاصيل المتعلقه
بهذه العمليه لكن هذه العمليه هي مستمره
تاخذ وقت وتتقدم تتاخر اعاده موضع اعاده
تمركز اعاده انتشار اعاده ضبط الموازين
داخل ارض المعركه
لذلك المعلومات هي تتحدث في كل دقيقه وهم
ينتظرون ان ينجلي الموقف ومن ثم يخرجون
بالمعلومات للراي العام شكرا جزيلا على كل
هذه المعلومات من مروي نزار بقداوي مراسل
العربيه
وينضم الينا من القاهره استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور طارق فهمي اهلا بك دكتور
طارق فهمي يعني دكتور حرب
تدور
وايضا اشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه من
السودان لعلنا استمعنا الى
تداعياتها على مروي انقطاع للكهرباء
والتيار الكهربائي والانترنت وهي التي لم
تصلها الاشتباكات فاذا كان الامر كذلك في
مروي فيمكن تخيل كيف يبدو الوضع في
العاصمه السودانيه
السودان الخرطوم برايك تداعيات هذه الحرب
ان استمرت على المدنيين خصوصا في ظل حاله
عدم الحسم
والضبابيه الموقف كيف ستكون
بالتاكيد طبعا بنك الاهداف سينفتح توقع
حضرتك خلال الفتره المقبله يعني خلال
الساعات تدريجيا تنفتح بنك الاهداف
واستخدام كل طرف له اوراقه الضاغطه ما
اشرت اليه حضرتك واتكرمت هو البدايه وليس
هو النهايه هو البدايه
لمحاوله المساس بالبنيه الخاصه بالاتصالات
والتحركات وغيرها وسيكون بطبيعه الحال معد
طبعا السيناريو التعامل بصوره او باخرى
لانه ما زلنا في الايام الاولى للمواجهه
وكل طرف سيسعى الى تحسين شروط شروط
التفاوضيه لاحقا باستخدام العامه العسكري
الممنهج المدنيين هم الذين سيتاثرون
بطبيعه الحال حاله الشلل الكبير في
السودان
ستمتد من المواطن البسيط الى مؤسسات
وقطاعات الدوله لا تنسى ان الدوله
السودانيه تعاني اصلا في حاله خلل وتازم
اقتصادي كبير ومعاناه المواطنين من تبعات
ما يجري حتى قبل اندلاع الاعمال العسكريه
فما بال حضرتك انها تزيد بهذه الصوره
موضوع قطع النت والخدمات الاخرى طبعا في
مناطق ربما ستكون اكثر تضررا وهي الاكثر
احتياجا كانت ومصنفه فيها انها اكثر مناطق
سوقا سوءا في السودان سواء كان في مناطق
الشرق او الجنوب الشرقي وفي مناطق الجنوب
وبالتالي اليوم نتحدث ايضا العاصمه وبعض
المدن الرئيسه اللي هي نقاط التمركز حول
العاصمه اعتقد ان المتاثر هو
المواطن السوداني وهتكون هناك تاثيرات
كبيره المشكله انه التوقع بالسيناريو
القادم في التعامل مع هذه الحاله سيكون
بطبيعه الحال هناك منشدات امميه ودوليه في
هذا السياق لكن لا اعتقد انه سيكون بمقدور
احد يعني محاوله التعامل بصوره حاسمه مع
ما يجري اوراق الضغط في اتجاه كل طرف مهم
حضرتك ان تتوقف امامها وكما تنزلنا فيه
المرحله الاولى وبالتالي سيستخدم كل طرف
ما لديه سيكون هناك تمشيط لبعض المناطق
قطعوا طرق واتصالات كامله يعني في
سيناريوهات كما تعلمها حضرتك معلومه
للجميع يعني الامور وهذا يعني ما يخشاه
الجميع يعني ان حتى لو تمكن طرف من ان
يضعف طرف اخر ستستمر المعارك ولو كانت
معارك شوارع لانه كما يقال بان هذا صراع
وجودي على سلطه من الجانبين وبالتالي اذا
لم يكن هناك اراده بالجنوح
للسلم ووقف اطلاق النار واجراء محادثات
فهذا لن يحدث حتى يثبت طرف انه اقوى اولاد
لديه اليد العليا على الطرف الاخر انا
ساعود لاستكمال الحوار معك لكن دعني فقط
اشرك الصحفي خالد الفكري من الخرطوم اللي
طلعنا على الاوضاع داخل مدينه الخرطوم مع
دخولنا اليوم الثالث من هذه الاشتباكات
القويه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خالد اهلا بك كيف تبدو الاوضاع
الانسانيه في العاصمه الخرطوم لجهه
الامدادات الاساسيه وايضا ما اذا كان
الناس ذهبوا الى اعمالهم ومدارسهم اليوم
ام لا
نعم انتصف النهار ابراهيم
ويعني سخانه
الحرائق واشتراد
الغذائي فهي سما الابرز الان في محيط
القياده وفي بعض الاحياء القريبه من محيط
القياده الان هناك وفق مصادر والشهود عيان
على ارض الواقع ان الجيش السوداني يعني
يسيطر والان هو انتقل الى مرحله اخرى
مرحله المطارده والملاحظه بعد انتهاء
المعركه الاكبر التي كانت في فجر اليوم
وانتهت في ربما نحو الساعه العاشره في
منطقه شرق المطارق الخرطوم وفي الطريق
الذي هو يعني كان يؤدي الى داخل القياده
بعد ان اعاده الدعم السريع تجميع صفوفي
وحاول فتح جبهه وصغرها في الجبهه الترق
المصادر وشهود ان الملاحقات الان تجري في
شارع الستين وفي بعض الاحياء شرق القطوم
في ملاحظه
لمنسوبي الدعم السريع الذين بعض منهم خلف
سيارته ولا هاربا ويفقد مصادر الوجود عيان
في احياء بشرق الخرطوم كما ان تحدثت الى
مصادر في جنوب الخرطوم في في احياء
الكلاكلات ابلغنا عدد منهم انه يعني شاهد
عدد من جنود الدعم السريع وهم غد اتوا من
ناحيه صالحه بعد ان تعرضت تعرض معسكرهم
الى القصف وبال من الطيران وانهم استطاعوا
ان ياجروا مركب ليقطع النيل الابيض من
الناحيه من الضفه الغربيه الى الناحيه
الشرقيه ويعني تم توقيفهم
الشرطه وهم الان غيدا
التوقيف اذا هذا المشهد الان الارضي انا
انا سالت ساعود لك لنستمع الى المزيد من
التفاصيل حول الاوضاع الميدانيه وايضا
الاوضاع الانسانيه في الخرطوم لكن ابقى
معي لنستمع الى تصريحات ادلبيها يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
للعربيه حيث اكد فيها سيطره الدعم السريع
على القصر الجمهوري ومقرات القياده العامه
وهو الامر الذي نفاه الناطق باسم الجيش في
تصريحاته للعربيه ايضا
نحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن
صيد المتواجد على طول كل الوزارات نحن
نسيطر على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم
والكباري كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه نحن
فقط عبر هذه القناه نطمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على
مواطنين او ينهب ممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه
رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل
المواطنين في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم
من المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها
خالد استمعت الى تصريحات الناطق خالد
الفكري الى هذه
الانجازات وما تم تحقيقه على الارض في
العاصمه الخرطوم وهو يتنافى مع ماء اوردته
لنا وايضا ما قالوا الجيش بانه كل هذا
ادعاءات كيف يمكن معرفه الحقيقه في ظل
تضارب الانباء بينما يصرح به الجيش
والدعم السريع
نعم نعم انا اعتقد انه ليس هناك تضارب ما
بين ما قلته وما قال
المسؤول في الدعم السريع انا استمدت الى
مصادر على ارض الميدان وشهود عيان
يعني ربما ما قاله
مستشار الدعم السريع يتطابق مع مع ما قاله
المتحدث
باسم الجيش الذي اكد ان الدعم السريع الان
هو داخل القصر الجمهوري وان هناك عمليات
واطلاق للنار في في فيديو زياده محدوده
داخل داخل محيط القياده العامه ولكن وفق
المصادر ايضا ان الدعم السريع الان هو
ينتشر في شارع النيل قباله القصر الرئاسي
وقباله جسر المكرو ويعني وربما هو بالتالي
بما ان الان جسر
هو بالقرب من القصر الرئاسه ولا منه الا
نحو 500 كيلو 500
متر من الناحيه الشرقيه فمن الطبيعي
قوات الدعم السريع هي في هذا الصندوق
الممتد النهي من الناحيه الشرقيه
والنهي الغربيه فبالتالي ليس هناك تضارب
فيما يعني ذكر من معلومات ولكن الان الخطه
التي اعرفها
وفق وفقا وفقا لما تحصلت عليه من مصادر ان
الان هناك خطه تتعلق
بالملاحظه والمداهمه
ويعني عدد كبير الان من القوات في الدعم
السريع هي الان موجوده في حي المطار الان
موجوده في حي المطار وربما الجيش بسبب
وجود عدد من الاسر ما زالت في حي المطار
سواء كان عسكريين او الميدانيين او بعض
الاسر التابعه
لسكن الجامعه الخرطوم
وبعض
المواقع الاستراتيجيه
خشيه استخدام القوه العنيفه مما يعني
يؤدي الى تساقط تساقط عدد من الضحايا
وتدمير البنيه التحتيه
محيط وسط الخرطوم نعود دعنا نعود الى
الوضع الانساني داخل الخرطوم الان فقط نود
ان نخصص جزء من تغطيتنا لمعرفه انعكاس كل
ما يحدث على اوضاع السودانيين كيف هو
الوضع الانساني الان في العاصمه الخرطوم
وكيف يتدبرون احوالهم الان
نعم يعني بدا استاذ ابراهيم يجب لفت
الانتباه الى ان هناك الان غذيفه وقعت
داخل قسم الطوارئ في مستشفى الشعب الذي
لعب كثيرا من محور محور العمليات ايضا
هناك قذيفه وقعت في مستشفى بشائر هو جنوب
الخرطوم وربما كانت هناك ماركه
في هذه المنطقه الوضع الانساني بشكل عام
يعني طواقم الطبيه تفشل حتى هذه اللحظه في
الوصول وتقديم المساعدات الى
علاج علاج
الجرحى او النقل البعض من الجثث التي ما
زالت موجوده في مناطق الاحداث بالتالي
يبدو الوضع الانساني صعب فبالتالي هناك
دعوات ومطالبات بان تكون هناك مده للهدنه
حتى يتم ويكون هناك ممر امن لخروج
العالقين
وتقديم المساعدات للجرحى والنقلهم الى
المشافي القريبه كما ان هناك ايضا ربما
احتكاكات جرد في محيط مستشفى الشرطه ربما
تاثرت المستشفى ببعض بعض
الاسلحه الثقيله والان الوضع الانساني في
محيط مستشفى الشرطه حرج الدعوه من قبل
المنظمات الطبيعيه والانسانيه بضروره
تقديم الدعومات العاجله
للتلقي علاج الجرحى ونقل الجثث وحتى يتم
اتخاذ الاجراءات المتعلقه
بمباراتها او يعني اخذها الى المسارح فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الانساني
الذي يتعلق به معاش المواطن السوداني في
محيط الاحياء التي تد
ور في المواطنين التزموا منازلهم وخشيه
سقوط
الاسلحه الثقيله والطلقات الطائشه عليهم
بدات بدا الان هناك في الازمات بسبب ال 72
ساعه من الحرب حيث اغلاق للمحال التجاريه
اغلاق لصيدليات فالوضع الانساني يبدو انه
يتعزم ما لم تكون هناك خدنا
تابعنا قبل اذا سمحت خالد تبعنا قبل قليل
عوده بث التلفزيون الرسمي الذي سيطرت قوات
الدعم السريع على مبناها نفهم من ذلك بانه
يتم البث من منطقه اخرى
في التلفزيون تحدثت معه صباح اليوم قال
بان الدعم السريع يسيطر على مقر التلفزيون
بالداخل
وكانت هناك مفاوضات حتى وقت متقر من الامس
بين القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع حتى
يخرجوا في ممر امن وحتى لا تتضرر الاجهزه
الفنيهات ولكن يبدو انه دارت معركه في
الساعات الاولى من الصباح وتم اجبار قوات
الدعم السريع على الانسحاب والخروج
فبالتالي الان هناك محطه بديله تم تشغيل
فيها موجات التلفزيون القومي وايضا موجات
الاذاعه التلفزيونيه الالزاع القوميه التي
توقفت عن البث لحين الصيانه وعوده
العاملين الى مواقعهم بطريقه رسميه بعد
تامين وتفتيش مقر التلف زيون من وجود اي
اسلحه قد تكون قابله للانفجار
وماذا يتم بث الان على التلفزيون هل
تابعتم
نعم نعم ما يبث الان هو عباره عن مواد
مسجله اناشيد وطنيه
وتاكيد على ان القوات المسلحه
الحاميه لمواطنين ولكن لا توجد اي مواد
مباشره حتى هذه اللحظه
الذي او بيانات شكرا جزيلا وصلت فكره انا
اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات من الخرطوم
الصحفي خالد الفكري ونشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره والخاصه بقناه العربيه من محيط
قياده الجيش الان
ما زالت يعني الاشتباكات
مستمره لكنها اقل وتيره مما كانت عليه في
صبيحه هذا اليوم صباح اليوم كانت قويه جدا
كان هناك قصف
مكثف على مباني مقر القيادات وايضا كان
هناك تحليق للطائرات في سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم
وارتفعت اعمده الدخان في سماء العاصمه لكن
الان الامور يبدو انها اهداف بكثير بمجرد
طلقات متفرقه
على كل حال نتحدث عن الوضع الانساني الذي
ذكرناه حيث اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان
ارتفاع حصيره ضحايا اشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم الى 97 قتيلا وفق البيان عدد
القتلى يتجاوز هذه الحصيله
منذ بدء الاشتباكات لاسيما وان الكثير
منهم لم يتم نقلهم من المستشفيات اما بسبب
الصعوبات في النقل او ربما
الظروف الخاصه بالاشتباكات على كل حال
نتابع
ثم نعود لكم
[موسيقى]
مع احتدام المعارك تبرز سيناريوهات الموقف
الراهن في السودان اولا رغم ضبابيه الصوره
فان سيناريو الحرب الاهليه مازال مستبعدا
فالجيش حتى المدنيين على عدم الانخراط في
المعارك الجاريه والسبب انها معركه سلطه
في المقام الاول بحسب مراقبين اما سيناريو
عدم الحسم فانه وارد ايضا مع تصعيد الدعم
السريع لهجومه ليلا بالمدفعيه لكن ميزان
القوه
لقوات الجيش هذا سيمكنها في النهايه من
الحسم ان لم يتطور الموقف الى حرب شوارع
في العاصمه السيناريو الثالث يرجح ان امد
الحرب لن يطول كثيرا اي انها معركه محدوده
زمنيا ويدعم هذا المؤشر انشقاقات من جانب
المنتدبين في الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى
الانشقاقات القياديه اما السيناريو الرابع
فهو الرهان على الوساطه الخارجيه وهو
القاسم المشترك بين الطرفين لكنه هجوم
الدعم السريع ليلين يشي بانهم يحاولون
الحسن قبل بدء الوساطه في حين يؤكد الجيش
انه لن يرضى بالوساطه قبل ردع الدعم
السريع وتنتهي السيناريوهات بالسيناريو
الاخير الذي يرجح ان تعود قوات الدعم
السريع الى دارفور مجددا والتحرك من هناك
كقوه انفصاليه يصعب نزاه شوكتها
ونعود الى ضيفي من القاهره استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور طارق فهمي اهلا بك دكتور
من جديد برايك اي سيناريوهات هذه اكثر
ترجيحا للحدوث سيناريو الحرب الاهليه عدم
الحسم معركه محدوده نسبيا ام الرهان على
الوساطه الخارجيه
هو طبعا لكل السيناريو وزن نسبي معين
تستطيع حضرتك ان تلمح يعني بنوضه وعناصره
في البدايات الاولى لا زلنا في الايام
الاولى من المواجهه وبالتالي سيناريو عدم
الحسم ربما هو يكون يعني السيناريو اللي
له وزن نسبي في التعامل المباشر لحين اتضح
الرؤيه كل السيناريو من السيناريوهات وارد
لكن بطبيعه الحال الاكثر ترجيحا هو عدم
الحسم لجمله من الاعتبارات اولا لازلنا في
مرحله تكشف مواقف كل طرف تمسك كل طرف به
مواقفه دفع كل طرف للطرف الاخر لحافه
الهويه عدم الانصات لاي مبادرات طرحت خلال
الساعات الاخيره استخدام القوى العسكريه
الممنهجه انفتاح بنك الاهداف الرئيسه لكل
طرف اذا هذا هو السيناريو اللي بنقيس عليه
هذا التوقيت في اذا كنا بنرجح السيناريو
اللي هو الاكثر واقعيه في التعامل مع
المشهد لكن يرتبط بهذا السينا عده امور
اول حاجه وهي نقطه مهمه هي مرتبطه حضرتك
بقدره كل طرف على الحسم نظريا
السيناريوهات رائعه اللي اشرت اليها حضرتك
لكن هناك قوه محفزات اقليميه ودوليه
واطراف اقليميه ودوليه ستغذي من الاتجاه
الى اي سيناريوهات الاكثر قبولا حتى اذا
توافرت الاراده السياسيه للطرفين
سيكون هناك
لتسهب في هذه النقطه لكن دعني اعرض هذا
الفيديو الذي وصلنا الان لطلبه محتجازين
في جامعه الخرطوم منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات
قبل ثلاثه ايام اذا نتابع هذه الصور
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ودي الحته اللي قاعدين فيها بالضبط كده
بتاع الطلاب في حته تانيه ومعانا شخص مصاب
وما عندنا مواني ونهاد الانقاذ في الاسراع
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ودي الحته اللي قاعدين فيها بالضبط كده
العمال في حته ثانيه ومعانا شخص مصاب
نعود لك دكتور طارق فهمي لا تستكمل فكرتك
حول سيناريوهات وارتباطها ايضا بعوامل
خارج السودان ايضا
وبالتالي هذه
القوه القوه المحفزه لكل سيناريو في
التعامل سيكون لها دور مباشر فيه اتجاه
اتجاه الى هذا السيناريو او طبعا القوه
العسكريه هي التي ستحسم كل ما نشاهده لانه
بطبيعه الحال بعض السيناريات اللي اشرت
حضرتك اليها هي تبقى في اطارها النظري
يعني الوسطات حتى الان غير واضحه المعالم
طبعا تتالي الوسطات سيؤثر بطبيعه الحال في
الاتجاه السلبي ليس صحيحا انه طرح اكثر من
مبادره في نفس التوقيت نتحدث عن الايجاب
نتحدث عن الفوضيه الافريقيه الاتحاد
الافريقي نتحدث عن وسطات بعض الدول ثم
نتحدث عن
الرباعيه الدوليه كل هذه المدخلات حضرتك
ستؤثر بطبيعه الحال على اي مسار سنمضي فيه
وبالتالي سيكون هذا الامر محل اختبار
المعادله سنستمع الى صوت الطبيعي الذي
ياتينا الان
من الخرطوم لهذه الاشتباكات
[موسيقى]
لدينا فيديو جديد مشاهدينا سنعرض لديكم
لكم هو حول ما يقال بانها قوه من الدعم
السريع داخل الاحياء السكنيه نشاهد هذا
الفيديو ايضا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
والتي
تاتينا من العاصمه الخرطوم صور خطوات
العربيه وتظهر
اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد في مساحه
شاسعه من العاصمه والتي تتركز للشبكات
فيها حول محيط مقر القياده وايضا
قصر الضيافه
ومنطقه المطار
وايضا حول التلفزيون اذا
حول المباني السياديه هناك اشتباكات
ونستمع لصوت اطلاق رصاص مكثف كنا شاهدنا
قبل قليل اطلاق رصاص
واستخدام اليات داخل المناطق السكنيه من
قبل قوات الدعم السري حسب ما تبعنا
بالفيديو
عليكم من جديد
المقطع الخاص بالطلبه السودانيين في جامعه
الخرطوم والذين قالوا فيه بانهم محتجزين
هناك
منذ بدء الاشتباكات قبل ثلاثه ايام نتابع
الطلاب في حته تانيه ومعانا شخص مصاب
وما عندنا اموال
ونقاس بالاسراع
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله في جامعه الخرطوم
ودي الحته اللي قاعدين فيها بالضبط كده
العمال في حته تانيه ومعانا شخص مصاب
وما عندنا اموال
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله في جامعه الخرطوم
ودي الحته اللي قاعدين فيها بالضبط
بتاع العمال في حته تانيه ومعانا شخص مصاب
وما عندنا مواني
اذا من جديد مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور
التي تاتينا من خلال الكاميرا العربيه صور
خاصه بقناه العربيه
وتظهر تصاعد الدخان الكثيف
و سماع
الرصاص عزيز الرصاص وايضا
ذوي قصف شديد في هذه المنطقه ومباني
محترقه ودخان كثيف يغلف
سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
اذا الاشتباكات مستمره في ظل حرب ايضا
اخرى تدور بين المعسكرين تتمثل في حرب
البيانات والانجازات كل طرف يدعي انها حقق
انتصار هنا وهناك وياتي نفي من الطرف
الاخر اليوم كان هناك بيانات على شاشه
العربيه
وتصريحات للمستشار السياسي للدعم السريع
وايضا للناطق باسم الجيش السوداني للعربيه
اكد كل طرف فيهم
تحقيق انجازات
ونفى انجازات التي حققها الطرف الاخر ابرز
ما قيل من قبل الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني
بانه سيتم استعاده مطار مروي وايضا جميع
مقرات القياده العامه
قيل بانها تحت سيطره الجيش وقال الناطق
باسم الجيش بان قواته تتصدى لمحاولات
اقتحام المقرات العسكريه وهو ما نشاهد
الان في الصوره قوات الدعم تحاول اقتحام
هذه المقرات الاستراتيجيه
والحيويه وذات الرمزيه الكبيره وقال باننا
ندير عملياتنا العسكريه بما يضمن حياه
المدنيين وحمايتهم
وقال بان فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر
البرهان تضليل
في المقابل مستشار السياسي للدعم السريع
يوسف عزت قال العربيه بانه
لا صحه لاستهداف احياء سكنيه خلال عمليات
قوات الدعم السريع شاهدنا قبل قليل صور
لاليات قوه الدعم السريع وهي تعمل داخل
الاحياء السكنيه اكد المستشار السياسي
صحه سيطره قوات الدعم على القصر الجمهوري
واكد ايضا سيطره قوات الدعم على مقرات
داخل القياده العامه وقال بانه تم فرض
سيطره قوات الدعم الكثير من المطارات
واعترف الجيش السوداني
بسيطره قوه الدعم على مطار مروي ايضا على
شاشه العربيه على كل حال
في ردود الافعال الدوليه
حيال كل ما يحدث قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه خلال لقاء مع نظيره البريطاني
جيمس كليبرلي الى بلاده تشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان واكد
اهميه الاتفاق ايضا مع الحلفاء على ضروره
وقف الاشتباكات الدائره بلينكن اضاف بان
الشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
لسكناتهم حيث يتطلعون الى دوله ديمقراطيه
من جانبه دعا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
طرفي الصراع الى اعطاء الاولويه للسلام
لانهاء الازمه
ثم تقلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في
السودان والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين
وعلى السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا
هنا في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء
في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق
مشترك حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على
ضمان حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفين نزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للذكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
في الاثناء حتى المبعوث الاماميه للسودان
فولكس جميع الاطراف على احترام التزاماتها
الدوليه بما في ذلك ضمان حمايه جميع
المدنيين وقالبرت ان الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع لم يلتزما بوقف القتال امس
والذي اعلن عنه لاغراض انسانيه الا بشكل
جزئي مشيرا الى خيبه امل شديده جراء تجدد
الاشتباكات
وتنضم الينا من الخرطوم الطبيبه السودانيه
صفاء عبوش اهلا بك دكتوره صفاء دكتوره
ماذا كانت ستعني الثلاث ساعات الهدنه
بالامس لو تم تنفيذها ماذا كانت ستغير
بالنسبه لك على الصعيد الشخصي وايضا
بالنسبه لكل السودانيين في هذه الظروف
الدقيقه
كانت تعني توفيقه ايصال امداد دوائي
كهربائي وغذائي وما الى المستشفيات التي
تستقبل الحالات الميدانيه
حتى اني استبداد الطاجن الموجود له اربعه
يوم بيطاج قاعد في البيت مرتاح عشان يشتغل
الحالات الموجوده في المستشفيات كانت
هتعني انه الليله ما حيكون في ناس مشتركين
في المنطقه بتاعت الصراع في مستشفى
الخرطوم ومستشفى الشعب ومستشفى جعفر بن
عوف وميض الخرطوم للطبيبات الخرطوم
للاطباء كان حتعني انه على الاقل في
الوضعيه صحي قاعد يستوعب كميه الجرحى
وعلاجه
ما معلوماتك عن طبيعه الوضع الصحي الان في
المستشفيات السودانيه
مستشفى تخصص لجراحه المخ والقلب والصدر
بنتكلم عن اخلاق مستشفى الخرطوم مستشفى
كبير فيه هو عنايه مكثفه فيه مبنى بتاع
جراحه اطفال وجراحه البوليه وفي كميه من
المرضع بالنسبه بنتكلم عن
اغلاق مستشفى المعلم مستشفى في المحيط
كوبري كوف
ر العلاجيه كبيره جدا بنتكلم عن اخلاق
مستشفى يونيفرسال برضو مستشفى في محيط
كوبر سعه العلاجيه كبيره جدا بنتكلم عن
وقف لكل الكوادر الطبيه في بيوته وعدم
تجديد الافطار زي ما قلت لك
به نقطه بنقطه اغلاق المستشفيات ما سببه
ماذا تتحرك
الدولي قرب المظلات بحري المناطق في شغله
الساعه 3:00 صباحا ما قاعدين نمشي رفع
المستشفى
احنا لو وصلنا ما في اخصائي تخدير
المستشفى نجد الانجاز الطبيه للشاشه
ومحاليل الوريديه وادويه موقفه للحياه
للمستشفى الكهرباء في المستشفى بايجازات
واحتمال لحد ياخذكم خلاص قرب التخلص وما
في مويه اصلا امبارح
بالبراميل لانه الخط العام بتاع بحري
انقطع لانه
كان يعني نفهم بان الاطباء يعني حتى لا
يتم تامينهم من قبل جهات معينه الهلال
الاحمر او جهات خاصه تؤمن تنقلاتهم من
والى المستشفيات انت تقولي بان هناك تواقم
تعمل منذ اربعه ايام ولم يتم استبدالها
هذا يعني بانه هناك شبه حظر تجول غير معلن
في العاصمه
تامين الحاجات اللي قلناها منظمات
الدوليه الطبيه الان جي اوزو دبليو اتش او
الصليب الاحمر الهلال الاحمر بالناس لحد
العملوه اجتماع
الساعه يساله من الدعم اللوجست محتاجين
نحن ما محتاجين دعم براوه نحن مسئمي ممرات
وتامين الشارع لاستبدالات الطبيه
طيب من خلال تواصلك مع الطواقم الطبيه
والزملاء في المستشفيات هل هناك تقديرات
لاعداد المصابين وضحايا هذه الاشتباكات
حتى الان
وابرز الاصابات التي تاتي الى المستشفيات
تتمثل بماذا
من صباح اليوم الاثنين نوصل لاي معلومه
لانه
بسبب القصف العنيف انا بتكلم معاكم سامع
صوت القفص في المظلات كل الاصابات اللي
عندها تلقي ناري في الصدر في البطن وفي
الاطراف ممكن تكون مصيبه اورنجيه وفي
الراس ونحن نتحدث معك ايضا نرى هذه الصور
المباشره والخاصه بقناه العربيه للاشتداد
وتيره القصف يبدو ان القصف عندما يشتد
يشتد في عموم العاصمه السودانيه ويهدا
يعني تاره ثم يعود لكي يشتد على كل حال
فقط تفضلي البقاء ساشير الى هذا الخبر
المتعلق ايضا بالوضع الصحي حيث تعرض
مستشفى ابن سينا وهو احد اكبر المستشفيات
الهامه في العاصمه الخرطوم الى الضرر في
بعض مبانيه بعد سقوط غذائف عشوائيه عليه
جراء اشتباكات المستمره والعنيفه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
وبخلاف الاضرار التي تقع على مستشفيات يجد
الاطباء والمرضى كبيره في الوصول الى
المستشفيات القريبه من اماكن اشتباك او
الطرق التي تؤدي اليها وهذا يعزز ما ذكرته
لنا
نعود لك دكتوره صفاء دكتوره فيما يتعلق
الامدادات التي تتحدثي عن ان هناك انقطاع
في الكهرباء والماء وايضا حتى المواد
الاساسيه في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه كيف
يتدبر او تتدبر الطواقم الطبيه نفسها
تبادل النار في محيط مستشفى المعلم
ومستشفى يونيفرسال ومستشفى الخرطوم
ومستشفى الفيصل بكل مستشفيات
هل نفهم من شهادتك بانه هناك استهداف
ممنهج المستشفيات
وصف الكراش بث مباشر بيانات
وتم جرح بعض الطواجن
طيب هل هناك اتهامات جهه باتجاه جهه معينه
تحميلها مسؤوليه هذا القصف ام انه قصف
مجهول غير معروف
القصف مسير بادانات وادعي ثقيله ما في
شايف حاجه
في مستشفى الشعب
بادانات لمبنى فيهم نتكلم عن مبنى مكون من
طواب من يعدد عنادل ونتكلم عن دراج كبير
هل تم اقامه مستشفيات ميدانيه بديله في
بعض المناطق لمعالجه الجرحى
ما ادت لي حاجه وما وصلنا ما قادرين
الملكه بتاعتنا وما قادر نواصل الاجابه
الطبيعه الخرطوم
كلها يتحرك عشان يوصل المستشفيات هناك
اشخاص بحاجه الى رعايه صحيه داخل المنازل
وحتى ادويه محدده او اسطوانات اكسجين
هؤلاء كيف يتعاملون مع ظروفهم الصحيه في
ظل هذا الوضع
الذي يشهد يعني اشتباكات منذ ثلاثه ايام
كبيره من المواطنين السودانيين يموتوا في
البيوت بسبب الخدمه الطبيه عيانين بتعيين
غسيل الكلى المكثفه وعياني ممكن يكونوا
قاعدين في بيوتهم للمستشفى
المبرمج في اطفال في المستشعفر
في اطباء وقوادر تطبيع في مستشفى بحري
الكهرباء
الطبيه ممكن يموت لانه ما في خدمه طبيه
قاعد توصله
الطبيه ما في ما عندهم ما عندهم قافله
يوم
انا اشكرك على شهادتك
الدكتوراه
صفاء كنتي معنا من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
ومع التحليق المكثف للطائرات الحربيه
للجيش يبدو ان السيطره على القواعد
العسكريه الجويه هي الشغل الشاغل الان لدى
قوات الدعم السريع فالسلاح سلاح الجو وفق
عسكريين هو النقطه الفاصله في المعركه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فمن يحكم
السيطره عليه يحسم المعركه
معركه السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه قوات
الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه تعلم
ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه فكانت
البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حمادي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مروي الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده مروي لاحتوائها على
اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم مركز
فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار وتليها
اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخ الطائرات
وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء السالم
العربيه
قبل ان نختم هذه الساعه من التغطيه نعرض
لكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
لسيطره الجيش على عربات تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع في محيط
القياده العامه التي تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
منذ ثلاثه ايام زي ما قعدت تقولوا اسرع
ربطكم في فتيلنا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
عربات الدعم السريع في غبطه القوات
المسلحه بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله
لاي مليجه رساله لاي ميليشيا الله اكبر
والعزه للجيش السوداني
وخلوها قبضنا ماشيه
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا معكم خلال هذه الساعه
الاخباريه ربما ابرز ما حدث خلال ساعات
الصباح واليوم والبيانات التي صدرت عن
الجانبين فيما يتعلق بهذه الاشتباكات على
كل حال هذه التغطيه مستمره على قناه
العربيه لكن على راس الساعه مع الزميل
نايف الاحمري تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات